and it's great to be here so I want to
start by giving a little background of
why I was interested in mental health
and then where I see the potential for
using technology so mental health is a
big problem but it's often kind of an
internal experience and there is there
is big stigma around it as well so it's
kind of silence that the kind of
understanding and recognition of mental
health is often silenced by this stigma
but if we look at an individual and
their behavior they're very very strong
signals in our everyday behavior that
our body almost broadcast that provide a
good indication in a reliable indication
of one's mental health and it could be
also used as an early indicator of
someone's mental health decline so
that's that's something that got me
interested in how can we use technology
to understand measure these signals and
under measure them early enough so that
we can intervene and as I said it's it's
a it's a big problem and if we look at
the statistics right one in five suffer
from mental health and it's not this
just an isolated problem individuals
with mental health often have other
problems so if we look at kind of
chronic conditions and these are some of
the top chronic conditions and there's a
significant fraction of comorbid kind of
depressive disorder right so overall if
you look at the percentages there's a
high percentage and some of them are as
a result of the illness so if you're
dealing with cancer it's it's not
surprising that someone might might be
depressed and others are just
co-occurring and what's so if we look at
that that it's quite prevalent but one
of the other things to think about so
overall in all chronic condition about a
third of people have some form of
depressive disorder and and most of the
time they go undetected and untreated so
in general less than fifty percent ever
actually get or seek treatment and in
chronic conditions the numbers are
similar but if we look at the outcome is
it has a huge outcome in the man
judgment of chronic illness as well the
user there is numbers that show that
actually the cost of treating
individuals with some form of depressive
disorder will for their chronic illness
is a two to three times more costly the
outcomes are were so the rate of second
heart attack goes up there is a diabetes
of poorly managed if you look at relapse
also in cancer patients that's higher so
not only does it actually we should
think about mental health as an isolated
problem it actually its effect is felt
throughout in our everyday kind of lives
and in our everyday well-being our
performance it's it has an effect
everywhere so what I want to kind of say
that where technology can play a big
role is that not only all of us struggle
with mental health right so mental
illness we were kind of isolating a
certain population which has diagnosed
mental health problems but we struggle
with mental health issues and if it's
not if we can't if we are not resilient
enough for can't manage it properly at
some point that likelihood of it
becoming a mental illness is high so the
the role of technology can also provide
not only help those with who have some
diagnosed illness but also help in the
context of having us all have better
mental health so what are some of these
behavioral signals and why do we think
we can use technology to detect it so
this is one of a standard questionnaire
that used in mental health screening
called the phq-9 it's a depression
screener and if you look at some of the
questions little interest in doing
things feeling down or depressed staying
trouble falling or staying asleep
feeling tired poor appetite trouble
concentrating moving or speaking slowly
that other people could have noticed a
lot of these are how we behave in the
world and we can use some of this you
can think and see that obviously there
are sensors that can measure that and we
can track that
so there is no need to rely on a
depression screener that's administered
once a year but you can actually try to
see if you can track these behavioral
symptoms automatically and actually
estimate a mental health score without
having to rely on these sporadic and
subjective measurements there's also
here's some quotes from patients people
who suffer with lifelong mental and less
often are aware of these behavioral
signals or their family members are so
here are some quotes from people from
various mental health problems did I
think the top left was from
schizophrenia mania about my legs bound
speech goes too fast bipolar disorder
and depression so in all of those cases
you can see kind of it that there are
changes in their behavior that are
significant and also sometimes that
people people are self-aware and and and
their family members can also keep track
of it but most of the time we don't
preemptively try to look for these
signals and our most of art very
educated enough to actually even
preemptively look at these signals and
think whether there's someone is
struggling with their mental health so
which kind of brought us to the thing
that what do we need to track so these
are some of the things that if you look
at questionnaires that is used in mental
health comes up repeatedly one's
physical activity sleep how they
socially interact with others how they
eat the the places they go and and their
mood and one of the that's that's kind
of looking at the literature and what is
being asked and what it being tracked we
wanted to kind of distill down to what
are some of the core set of behaviors
that we want to measure and and get once
we measure them can we actually reliably
track someone's mental health and and
how does it compare with some of the
standard measures that are used for
looking looking at decline or
improvement in health so one of the
good things is that our phones can track
a lot of that right so we have a huge
kind of ownership and penetration of
smartphone users that have sensors but
we're also seeing a growing a set of
wearable sensors that are tracking much
more physiological signal as well as can
be used as for actuation that has
promised so right now is it is a great
time to think about how we can get as
many of these signals as we possibly can
and also see how effective it is in in
predicting someone's mental health and
also managing so the first is activity
and I'm not going to talk much about it
as James at the combine I think 10 12
years ago almost I started working on
physical activity recognition and now I
think it's pretty much a lot of the
basic simple activities that require
tracking or can be useful as a solved
problem and there's a whole bunch of
wearables probably most of you are
wearing one thing or the other and James
is probably wearing three well you're
not wearing three today that that can be
used to track our activities but one
thing I think that physical activity
tracking at least in terms of whether
someone's walking being sedentary
another is fairly kind of widely
available and fairly accurate that we
can use it so I'm not going to actually
kind of talk about more on the research
side of that one aspect that I want to
talk a bit more about is one's social
interaction their changes in their voice
as you could see that one of the the
court said I even speak too fast so if
you however our vocal characteristics
changes and also mood and the the
channel I want to focus on is audio
where I have a deep interest in and have
a lot of experience working in and
particularly looking at kind of voice
and one of the things that always come
up is when you're thinking about so that
one of the oldest sensors on our phone
is is the microphone but you will also
say hang on a second you want to record
my conversations 24-7 that's
that's not okay but if we look at so the
privacy is a big big factor and that's
some of the kind of earliest work that
we did and one one of the things that
was interesting when I was doing some
work with audio if I worked with kind of
folks in the speech side it's like oh
you don't want to record all the audio
but you're throwing away so much data
like are you crazy but at the same time
nobody would actually carry the device
around if we can record it all the audio
or even thinking about keyword detection
so the first thing we did is what we
call like privacy sensitive processing
most feet where we explicitly
destructively process the audio real
time so that we cannot reconstruct
intelligible speech and it kind of
arises from a very very simple speech
production model that people have been
using in electrical engineering for
decades is that you have kind of the
source filter model right so the source
is the kind of vibration of the vocal
folds in response to airflow from the
lungs and then your vocal trap kind of
shapes the spectrum to generate phonemes
and words so if you actually get rid of
the information about the filter the
focal kind of the shaping of that
spectrum you can still get information
about the source the periodic kind of
signals the pitch or the vibration that
you feel when you speak and throw away
information about the about the content
and what that allows us to do is detect
when someone speaking but not only that
detect rate of speed how fast or slow
someone speaking their pitch or the
intonation so how is their pitch have is
it flat monotonous or there is a lot of
variability so that's really useful in
terms of emotion and mental health so
for example in mental health depression
people talk about this terminology
called psychomotor retardation right
that basically means that you slow down
you're walking rate slows down your
speaking rate slows down so you can
actually get that from this vocal just
looking at the stylistic aspect without
ever having to record what someone is
saying and this is something that we've
done of quite a while ago and
what we showed that we can use just
regular microphone to detect a person
speaking ray turn-taking conversations
and with with about depending on how
noisy the environment is with between
like seventy-five percent to eighty-five
percent accuracy enough that we can get
a broad coverage of someone's a kind of
conversations throughout the day so we
don't have to just rely on phone
conversation so the first experiment
that we did and that was quite a while
ago was I'm looking at physical and
mental health in an older like a
retirement community when I was still at
Dartmouth and just saying that how and
it was kind of the first experiment that
looked at can we look at how its
measured now using some of these
standardized well-being survey and can
we actually relate our measures with
those so how much we speak kind of
matters so here imagine this person in
blue who is talking to a bunch of people
so these are showing different
conversations they're having the length
is showing the different durations of
conversations the number of people that
talk to now if they change their
behavior to something like this and it's
persistent so we all have days that are
variable right but if someone is has a
significant reduction in the group of
people they're talking to the duration
that persists for two weeks or more
which is often what's used in kind of a
lot of these screeners you know
something might be going on and it's a
it's a good time to actually try to
check in and that's exactly what was
what some of the things that we looked
at so we looked at a various range of
surveys that are used for older adults
so physical activity as well as physical
and mental health I will just talk about
the mental health aspect we saw we've
done analysis on the physical health but
one thing we saw is that very very
simple measures of how much someone
interacts and how frequently really
correlates very well with these measures
and this was done in a small population
of older adults half for about a
three-week period and and which gave us
our first kind of encouraging and
promising results that we can actually a
to not we are able to track meaningful
measure and actually correlating it with
measures that doctors use so one of the
kind of challenges is that can you how
do you make the information that you're
gathering very digestible to clinical
practitioners so I think there is a big
kind of adoption gap in a lot of the
latest and greatest technology we build
and thinking about how can it integrate
with the clinical workflow of a
physician so that they can easily adopt
it and know how to interpret it so one
of the things of what we've focused
quite a lot on is trying to connect with
those measures or say we can predict
scores we can really connect it with the
tools that they're used to so the next
thing that we looked at is going yeah
Michael question for a minute so in the
middle one like your r square value
would be like point six which means you
clinic sixty percent of variation in one
of the mcs survey is now wondering is
that if you were to deploy this what is
that is that amazing is that good enough
to hit like macro changes but like the
the subtle ones you're going to miss
like what does that mean if you were to
actually get it that's a good question
and I think this is as I said was done
for on a population about eight people
over three weeks right so it's a small
subject so right now what we are doing
is we have a clinical trial not with
depression but schizophrenia which I'll
show you some results on of trying to do
longer term prediction and seeing a
little bit more of what are some of the
features that associate more strongly
than others to to see how where we can
get from there I think this is true
preliminary is the results to answer
that question but that's where we are
going is looking at can we actually
predict the onset of relapse how early
can we do it and what are the behavioral
measures that are robust and the other
thing that we are seeing in that case
which I'll talk at towards the end is
there is a lot of interpersonal
variability this was a fairly
homogeneous group of adult living in a
very it's a high-functioning group of
adults living in a very
scale retirement community and they were
very well informed about their health so
which we cannot so there was a lot of
homogeneity in this population which the
schizophrenia population is the complete
opposite their lower SES the most of
them don't have jobs and then there is
also kind of their at a competitive
function level of fifth grades so I
think we'll have more answers and I'll
show you some of the results at the end
but I don't think we have a conclusive
answer yet and what we have is that
there is predictive power but what we
don't know in in this case is how much
variability is there person to person in
context why's that to say how much
variance we can explain or like how
better but one of the things that is
interesting to think about is there is
some signal which might be noisy but it
could still be used as an early
indicator so one of the things that we
are doing with the hospital system now
and that's part of the the start of that
we found it or not and the research side
is can we raise an alert to a case
manager so that they can do some sort of
follow-up it could be a soft follow-up
as just asking them sending a text
message about their medication or it
could be if we raise a higher learn to
come in to see a doctor so right now a
lot of the final kind of diagnosis is
done by the clinician but it's it's kind
of integrated in terms of the the the
clinical scores that they're used to
dealing with how that colonists are the
Aqua but is it sort of like is it a
gentle slide from one side to the other
does it tend to be something where
people have like a phase change and if
so like how how stretched out is it
instead of the population so I'll show
I'll show you a result for that sketch
if any that you kind of can see a trend
there's a little bit of fluctuation
which could be a reporting bias so we've
looked at smoothing that trend but once
it's almost like if you start going down
then you can go down quite rapidly is to
catch it at the right kind of point that
you can have and that's what clinicians
also say that if you can catch it or
enough you can intervene but when
someone is just going downhill it's
really hard to kind of prevent that
slide so what we're trying to kind of do
is that kind of tipping point yeah and
the questions okay you see this as in
the future having the ability to make
automated recommendations to people or
to quietly take measures to change
people's behavior rather than only
interfacing with clinicians because
there are a lot of people who are not in
any sort of care situation who can
benefit from this yeah so I'll give you
some examples of how we're doing
intervention to at the end but yes one
of the reasons we focused on arm
collisions is we think that there is a
gap of adopting this technology and
clinical practice and we wanted to see
what do we need to do to get clinicians
to have the buy-in so that was an
explicit focus but absolutely right that
we can actually do a lot even and
particularly kind of preclinical
population if you're not diagnosed are
there certain things and I'll show you
some work that we're doing with kind of
stress and anxiety measurement where we
are doing direct intervention all right
okay so another aspect we looked at is
can you detect stress from voice so if
you even have first time when you gave a
talk you probably could tell from your
voice that you're getting stressed out
right and our voice does have kind of
does change in terms of in response to
our emotions and and we didn't this is
not work that we first proposed there's
a lot of work in speech processing where
the speech recognition system look for
adapt to emotions what we wanted to do
is build it in a mobile system so we
actually looked at a lot of the features
in the literature and and try to see if
we can in a mobile noisy setting
characterized stress from voice and one
of the things there we also have to do
is these some of these features are
computationally intensive can we
actually do it so that we don't kill the
battery of the system so a lot of this
was like mobile system kind of
engineering to think about how you can
accurately
detect pull out good chunks of voice
data to classify stress and so we had
this system that was deployed and also
the other thing what are some of the
challenges because there is a light kind
of human voice that you can have a
one-size-fits-all human the stresses has
a lot of interpersonal variability based
on age gender as well as some people
where you will see that talk faster when
they stress some people talk slower when
they're stressed so there are there is a
lot of kind of very abilities that go in
a different direction so one of the
things is that how can you actually
build a model of stress that adapts to a
person without requiring a lot of label
data from them and we looked at some
real-time kind of model adaptation so
one thing is you can get small amount of
user label which is doing this
supervised adaptation which is a
standard with a lot of also speech
recognition system to do it one of the
things we wanted to look at is based on
the confidence level of our stress kind
of one universal model can we
personalize and one of the things that
we did is that we do sacrifice accuracy
so generally we got in the range of like
eighty-three percent but if we use
unsupervised kind of adaptation we get
about it performs lower at seventy-eight
percent but you can get good enough data
that potentially you could use so that
was another and all that kind of pushing
beyond what you can get from from this
voice data to get better understanding
of someone's mental health the other
aspect where we see changes is also
people breathing like when they have
anxiety their breathing rate gets
affected heart rate other things so can
we actually get confuse your logical
signals and that was another thing we're
kind of I'm interested you'll see that
like audios I'm kind of trying to get as
much from audience and area that I'm
quite interested in so one of my
students it was thinking about how you
can actually design a microphone that
could actually get more subtle body
sounds so we actually designed a special
purpose microphone which now I'll show
you the prototype is not something you
wear but ultimately it's envisioned
it would be something like a headphone
that goes behind your ear it's a bone
conducting microphone that you want to
listen to subtle vibrations in your body
to conduct it through the boat and
something that you can wear all the time
so one of the biggest challenges is that
you when you're walking around there's
so much external sounds that if you want
to look at detect things like breathing
it's hard to do so if there's two things
one is it has a membrane here where the
acoustic impedance is matched with the
kind of skin so that you have maximal
transference of sound from the body and
then there is this acoustic kind of the
the it's basically a ballistic gel that
strives to isolate or damp and external
sound so you really get very very good
signal-to-noise ratio so that was kind
of thinking about how do you take kind
of in a noisy environment get good
signal this is what it looks like that
you'll never wear in a regular setting
but this was the kind of first prototype
and I want to show you a video of it
looking at breathing so here let's see
I'm taking long deep breaths we fought
this is a high intensity in the reading
was a rate remains low so you can see
it's trying to get it breathing rate and
intensity as breathing begins to
normalize you will notice little
fluctuation of rate with a significant
drop in the intensity
as breathing rate increases you'll
notice the simultaneous in Greece and
the breeding intensity throughout I dig
how many times you can do it without
passing out now anyway so this kind of
shows one of the things we show that you
can actually go outdoors and it's still
10 detected where if you had a regular
microphone you would and it will all get
kind of washed away with the noise and
the other thing we look at is not only
can you get at these internal kind of
body Sigma but you can also use it to
get at some basic detection of eating
which is another thing that we were
interested in so if you look at this
kind of spectrogram these are some of
the frequency response of the audio so
this is x axis is time y axis is
frequencies that we're looking at how
the signal looks like for various
activities so we had the breathing be
breathing but also kind of eating
characterization and that one thing we
wanted to kind of explore is eating
detection automatically is still an
unsolved problem right we can't do that
can we even know instances of when
someone's eating how frequently is
someone's eating whether they eating or
drinking so that was kind of the level
that we were looking at characterizing
so that's it this was if we can actually
get a clean signal which you from the
spectrograph we can see it's a fairly
kind of lean Sigma the classification
problem isn't that difficult and can we
detect these sounds and again we were
able to look at these kind of variations
we don't know kind of we can't tell what
a person is eating but we can kind of
say crunchy food not crunchy food or
someone's taking kind of drinking
something we don't know what they're
drinking but at least we know eating
moments when it was using the same kind
of microphone that we I showed you that
we use for breathing so it's a it's a
kind of a tool that could be used for a
diverse range of detection of activities
and a lot of these wearable systems that
we build is kind of built as than a kind
of two modules where you have a little
bit of processing on the sensing end but
then you send the data over to the
smartphone that does more processing
there is a Bluetooth communication and
it's doing it so this is how we are from
the the systems point of view designing
it so the other thing in eating that we
try this can you even know that the
color of the food someone's eating and
and the reason why we did that was
towards a little bit of intervention
which I won't go into the too much
detail today is we know that there so
there has been research by the food and
brand a kind of branding researches of
how you can affect a person's perception
of how much food there is on a plate
using some kind of perception bias and
we wanted to see if we can build
technology to do that so this is a plate
at one of my students built it can
actually say it has a RGB sensor built
in that can detect the color of the food
and it will change the color of the
plate so you can see it's doing this
automatically and the thing that we
wanted to do is can you actually affect
the perception of how much food that
there is on the play so that people
serve themselves less so what we saw is
that we can actually affect the
perception of food people think that it
is and this is also done in like
psychology the based on an illusion
called Daboo solution where you can
actually say that the based on the
radius and and whether if you have the
same color you have the perception that
it's filling in more and and you can
actually we didn't do the experiment yet
where we see if actually people are
serving less food but we did ask them
the question where do you think there is
more food and we see the similar results
so the idea is that you can get maybe
some characteristic of what type of food
they're eating and ultimately be able to
affect the amount of food that they're
eating the other thing that we've also
used in terms of getting at food is just
taking image and crowdsourcing it and
this is we copied basically work that's
out there with a little bit more kind of
tweaking there's Christoph Kyle's at
Harvard is done plate made and pretty
much the similar
but so we're exploring different
parallel ways that you can get some
information about food without requiring
people to log in journal and and
especially if we want to do with
population with mental health it's very
hard to do so this is kind of gives you
an idea but it's still a very harm I
would say very much a kind of an active
research space where there isn't a good
solution and anyone who can actually
track food automatically will make a
kind of a huge advance of what we can do
so far okay so I'm going to move in as
you can see i'm going to kind of step
through unless there's question the next
thing that we want to track is sleep
yeah I think it's fairly obvious place
on how much the studies that have been
done and even you know our own personal
experience how much food can affect our
mental health so I mean I mean are you
trying to sort of create some kind of
hair device that might be able to track
what we are eating in relation to our
mental health and the reactions that we
have yeah so what we are going to do is
basically thinking about a comprehensive
picture of behavioral kind of changes
that we see associated with mental
health and then influence it so we are
at different stages of that kind of
development and some of them were saying
oh can we influence it someone although
we can't track it properly but the idea
is that and I'm kind of phq-9 as a model
and i'll show you another server that's
used for bipolar disorder is these are
the behavior that come up repeatedly and
can we track significant changes in
their behavior and basically ultimately
we want to combine all these behavior
and say what's the person's daily rhythm
our routine and if there is multiple
dimensions that we see significant
change that is something that's
noteworthy right week one of our
dimensions might be off for a little bit
because we're traveling some deadlines
but if a lot of our behaviors have
significant changes that persistent that
says something about our mental health
so sleep see there's lots of also
gadgets out there to track our sleep one
of the things we wanted to look at is
going beyond sleep to understand the
person's chronotype because we talked
about a lot of how much you sleep but
actually based on your body clock when
you sleep is also very important right
if you're a late type person and you go
to bed early and forced to wake up early
even if you get your eight or seven
hours of sleep you might feel more tired
so that's one thing that we looked at so
for populations that are active phone
users what we found is that just looking
at the phone usage pattern and what apps
that they use we can actually get that
not only predict how much this lead but
also their chronotype so for example if
someone wakes up and it's checking
facebook or looking at today doing some
kind of cyber loafing and it takes them
a while to get out of bed they they're
more likely kind of maybe a late
chronotype having to wake up early for
their class this we did with a student
population versus if someone is up and
active and doing early or doing some
more cognitively intensive kind of apps
like okay actually composing an email
and sending it out so one of the things
that we looked at is just looking at the
phone usage and screen on and off we
were able to predict someone sleep
patterns also their chronotype but that
didn't get us to sleep quality and
completely unobtrusively how we can get
at sleep quality and right now there are
various similar work out there of
looking at Wi-Fi to other other signals
in terms of kind of movement in bed one
area that we explored was using kind of
Doppler radar that can we actually
unobtrusively measure sleep from a
bedside device and it's basically what
cops used to pull you over right of it's
basically shooting a kind of a an EI
wave and looking at the reflection to
estimate short range kind of Doppler
to estimate various aspect of changes
physiological changes that we see in
sleep so here's the kind of a quick
overview of how how it works we have so
we have kind of a 20 of 24 gigahertz
kind of Doppler radar that is kind of
transmitting towards your body it can
easily go go through blankets and sheets
so that's not an issue so as we have so
it kind of looks like this and someone's
breathing their hearts beating and what
we would actually see that is these
movements due to these vibration will
create like a phase-shifted signal that
we want to capture and analyze and
extract patterns out of so here we can
actually look at the frequency and based
on that we can actually say see that you
can get at people's breathing rate and
heart rate you can also look at movement
which we can filter out and what what we
do is by using kind of band pass filters
we actually focus on regions where we
think someone's breathing rate is heart
rate is an estimate their heart rate so
for example when someone's falling
asleep their heart rate actually slows
down breathing so we are trying to look
at continuously measure these signals
and changes to detect when someone's
falling asleep and so we do a better job
when we want to do sleep wake cycle but
if we're looking at stages of sleep it's
still kind of in the eighty percent
range so I want to kind of show you a
video of this working
so this is kind of showing some filtered
signal his postdoc Kane who volunteered
for this video and the audio is
amplified so he doesn't he's not really
snoring but so the idea is that you can
try to get all these signals and
ultimately kind of combine them to get
at how long it takes for someone to fall
asleep how many interruptions they have
and sleep researchers use something
called sleep efficiency how the total
time you spend in bed over how long it
took you to fall asleep so the how
quickly so there is a certain amount of
sleep efficiency that you want if
someone just wants to bed right away
also that indicates something that you
are too tired so there's this a shirt
that now if there's a i forgot the
company that makes it so you have this
vest that has all these kind of
physiological sensors so you can build a
heart rate breathing rate and it has
accelerometer so we use that as getting
the ground sugar you don't know so this
was done so the shirt was is through a
company so with the sleep lab they do a
lot of EEG and pulse oximeter so this
was actually trying to get at the
respiration rate on heart rate through
this very tightly just fitted best it's
actually the so I forgot the name of the
company that makes it but we collected
so right now actually sweat eggs group
which who is using this in the sleep lab
so we are going to get some benchmark
with of the sleep lab data which in this
case we don't okay so i will kind of now
move to some of the case studies in
specifically in the mental health realm
that we've used a bunch of these in so
just like we
we have made a great progress
commercially research-wise in actually
measuring our life right like life is
quantified but one of the things that I
think we fall short on is that people
are not just numbers and how do you
actually take action based on this
quantified data and that's what we have
been interested in in the mental health
room so I'm going to talk about two case
studies what is mood rhythm which was an
application designed for individuals
with bipolar disorder and it was based
on looking at a specific type of therapy
that is used called interpersonal social
rhythm therapy where people are asked to
kind of keep track of their social
rhythms which is these five questions
when they go to bed the first contact
when they started work school or other
activities dinner and going to bed so
again you can see that there are all
these things that kind of repeat in
terms of the measure that we're
interested in so we actually work with
one of the authors Alan Frank who
designed a survey to see whether we can
actually track this behavior using
smartphones and what they do is they
collect this data for two weeks and
based on how regular they are in their
time in these routines the estimate what
they call a social rhythm score and for
bipolar disorder patients actually a
deviation from routine can trigger a
manic or depressive episode they're more
I'm sensitive to destruction in their
own biological rhythm also they're more
sensitive to disruption in their kind of
this their effects of jetlag are more
extreme so they're kind of there so we
are more robust to kind of destruction
and our kind of what our alignment
between our internal chronotype and how
we live our lives or daily routines so
that sensitivity if you see this
disruption can have a detrimental effect
so what they try to do in this therapy
is to get people to be more regular
almost like living like a monk that you
do everything at a regular time and
they look at is if you have deviation
between kind of a half a standard
deviation that it will something that
they want to correct and they look at
overall kind of deviation across these
activities over time to see what your
overall destruction in your routine is
so what we wanted to do is to use kind
of the sensor data to infer the social
rhythm score automatically and see if we
can do that because based on that score
the the therapist takes action on what
behaviors to focus on and whether
they're actually declining so we saw
that we are able to kind of
automatically infer this is a score that
ranges from zero to seven so within one
point and and what we can also do is
there is they usually use the 3.5 as a
kind of cutoff point between stable and
unstable behavior so we can look at kind
of stability of the patient and the idea
is that we can then because this is
something that the clinician sees every
two weeks people are poor about tracking
their behavior that we can continuously
track changes and go from one kind of a
reactive model to a proactive model as
soon as we see some early warning signs
and yeah or is it a lot of people won't
like one a lot of these things trash
talk a little bit so this has been done
kind of iteratively over certain several
studies with patients with bipolar
disorder ranging from understanding
their concerns about privacy to how they
would use it whether they would want to
use it and some of them have been done
through the course of almost three to
four months studies two things that have
been in about three weeks studies in the
range of patients from 10 patients to 50
patients so what we found is that
individuals who actually suffer from
severe mental unless particularly things
that our lifelong are actually quite
open to using this technology because
the quality of life is so poor when they
have a manic episode
or depressive episode that there is kind
of an appreciation for how these kind of
technology can help but looking at
privacy is important right so for
example they don't want something on
their phone to pop up about that reveals
that they might have bipolar disorder
right how you design this interface is
important we're actually very happy
about something happening completely in
the background like passively because it
doesn't really look at kind of some of
the privacy or some kind of social
aspects of living with that in lesson
with bipolar disorder there are some
really very productive and high
functioning individuals who might want
to manage that we didn't have so overall
generally people were quite keen on
using and we have actually had some
individuals one case that it was very
compelling there was a 65 year old
gentleman who never used a smartphone
and would actually just kind of take it
out of the box and answer some questions
and never use the sensor to actually
carrying with him on in his pocket all
the time and felt that actually that
some of the feedback which I'll show we
gave him was very helped him that there
was almost like a guardian angel looking
after him and that was his kind of quote
so I think overall generally it's been
fairly positive so what we wanted to do
is actually use this kind of behavioral
data to provide behavior triggered
messaging so that was one of the first
step that we wanted to look at was
simple so we can actually get at these
rhythm scores but we can look at where
so green is when someone is in routine
orange starting to deviates and read
significantly deviating so for example
in this case you see the sleep is
significant the disruptor then we can
kind of say that your sleep has been
irregular these are the three strategies
people have found useful so it's more
kind of these short cycle kinda like
interventions that a clinician would
give but done in a context sensitive
manner so it's a very kind of simple
idea but it's being delivered just in
time when they might need it but the
other aspect of how do we get
to regulate their behavior was I'm
thinking about taking into account the
traits of the illness in the design so
um kind of researchers have found that
bipolar kind of in bipolar disorder
they're individuals who have kind of
bipolar disorder they they're more kind
of sensitive to their reward system is
kind of sometimes more active so they
that's ends up them becoming doing
compulsive shopping gambling other types
of addictive behavior so we wanted to
see can we actually exploit that in a
positive way so we looked at how they're
maintaining your routine and just kept a
streak and see if it affects their
behavior so this is destroying how many
days in a row have you actually
maintained that routine and we did some
iterative design with actual patients so
one of the first thing we found is that
this streak is kind of hot full but also
sometimes people felt that oh if you've
had like a series of good days and then
you have going coming out of depression
it might seem an unreachable goal so we
actually reset it on a weekly goal with
the patients are actually found very
much much more useful in terms of
something that they can see pushing them
in the right direction but also not get
discouraged when they are in a more
negative state so I think one of the
things is the lesson for us has been to
actually think about the illness what
you can export to have positive behavior
chain and also see what works and what
doesn't work and iterate so I want to
kind of give another example which I'll
do kind of quickly is this is probably
our largest study so this is actually
our clinical trial with the goal of
recruiting 150 patients for who are we
are going to track for a year it's
recruited from a hospital in Long Island
part of the long island jewish hospital
system called Zucker hillside and these
are patients with schizophrenia
we've been within one year of
hospitalization so one of the things we
wanted to have a population that have a
significant chance of relapse so that we
are able to look at predictability of
our system and relapse and and look at
variation so here's some of the things
that we are measuring but also here are
some of the self-reported questions that
being asked in terms of in schizophrenia
that are you seeing things hearing
voices which is common are you thinking
about harming yourself and and what we
wanted to do is can we predict these
measures from sensor data and these are
asked every three days so our goal has
been to look at sensing data to predict
the EMA scores and see how reliable it
is and one of the things in the interest
of time because I want to save some time
for question is we saw a lot of
interpersonal variability in our data so
here it's basically the feature data
projected into two dimensions so we have
about sixty six dimensional data of
different features for my senses it's
showing its color-coded by user so you
see a different grouping this was
color-coded by the similar EMA score so
although this is much more mixed but you
kind of see the EMA scores with the same
kind of scores cluster together what we
wanted to do is see if we can track the
score over time and this is where
actually so you see over 120 days one
individuals self-reported EMA score so
you can see it kind of fluctuate but
it's going up and down based on their
state and what we also looked at is
smoothing that data so that we can get
an underlying trends and what we saw is
that if we take that smoothing trend we
can actually predict further in advance
so the underlying trend is much more
robust so we look at this sensitive and
we this is kind of showing that you have
some level of smoothing and
cross-validation interval size meaning
if how far in advance of a kind of a
chunk that you leave out can you predict
accurately so as you go further back in
time your predictive party
but if you are trying to get at the red
line you have much more predictive part
than if you're trying to play the blue
line and if you talk to a clinician off
and they will say that the blue line is
a lot of subjective variability where
you might want to get it down the line
train anyway so this is this actually so
so far their 34 individuals in our
experiment armed and they've been
recruited it's a it's impossible to roll
in row 150 schizophrenia patient in one
go it's a rolling window roll and we
have about three to eight months of data
that's worked on so looking at kind of
the predictability so it's encouraging
but we still have a long way to go and
we have only had seven relapse it's not
enough to really see how accurately we
can predict relapse so hopefully that
will be as we get more more data so I
want to end by so this gives you an
example of how we are deploying it and
some of the iteration but I want to end
by kind of saying that we're behavior
change is important and being able to
effectively do behavior changes the
crucial but individuals who suffer from
mental health problems expecting them to
be highly motivated to change their
behavior is is almost an impossible task
right and I know it's it's it's all fair
to expect that they should be highly
motivated tracking all their behaviors
and make changes so kind of stepping
back if we think about where we were in
terms of behavior tracking right we used
to journal and then we had funds where
we used to use journaling right and now
we have sensors that make that behavior
tracking almost invisible and a lot of
behaviors we don't have to do anything
to get some estimate of how it
functioning so that made me kind of
think about is one of the and 1 of the
area that we've been exploring a little
bit is can we actually make the
intervention disappear and how can we
how can we design that and and actually
you know what inspired me in this area
was like after reading kind of the book
Thinking Fast and Slow right Daniel
Kahneman's book and then they talked
about that we have these two systems
right system one and system two and
system one is
a kind of fast automatic response and
then our conscious system where we
actually make conscious decision so can
we actually think about the automatic
responses and design technology that can
leverage this automatic response to
trigger behavior change so that's
something that we've been actually
toying around with a little bit I'll
give you one example actually I might
give you one and a half so one is can we
actually regulate stress so it in in a
way that just works in real time without
requiring any motivation or effort from
the individual so this relies on so and
we've been kind of looking at some
theories in psychology where so there is
this whole notion of how you're aware of
your bodily signals right so when you
have when you're you're having racing
heartbeat you can realize you're getting
stressed right so here what we looked at
is if you can give heart rate measure
heart rate and give feedback can you
actually regulate stress levels so what
we do is give false feedback so we do
our stress induction experiments so this
is called the tree or stress test and
then we measure their heart rate and we
actually give feedback that's lower than
their actual heart rate and see if we
can change their perception of anxiety
so so this is basically has three
actuators that gives the feedback and
this is what we have looked at in terms
of anxiety so the control is we don't
give any feedback then we get feedback
about the real heart rate with the slow
heart rate which is the false feedback
and we get just vibrate and don't tell
them anything and we can see that
they're actually what we saw this was
done about with 65 people and we
consistently saw a significant kind of
reduction or no change in in their heart
a kind of anxiety level pre and post so
this is one example where you can have
real-time effect without requiring that
much motivation and effort yeah
intervention so the psychology
literature says yes we haven't done that
yet so that people and in most of the
people didn't realize that didn't get
interrupted by the the heart the kind of
heart rate vibration but in the
vibration groups some people said that
yeah I noticed something and I was
thinking maybe it was my heart rate and
it seemed know enough but I thought it
was I was more stressed than I was but
maybe I wasn't so people were doing some
interpretation we don't really know
what's kind of going on out on and we
don't have enough data but that's
something that we'll have to test yeah
yeah she wanted to actually get the IP
before we could hit our you become
deadline but I think because you are
actually then stressing people out so we
haven't done that yes so very explicitly
every it will be more difficult the
other thing that we tried and I want
kind of go into it also can you affect
the way how people speak and this was
kind of based on you know how you if you
smile you feel happier it's not that
when you're happy so can we actually
change the way people speak to actually
affect how they feel we don't know the
answer yet but what we did is actually
have a microphone that would sorry of
speaker that we're talking on the pitch
of the person and feeding it back to the
person in a very low amplitude to see if
we can manipulate their pitch and our
kind of early results so and
particularly we wanted to see if we can
lower their pitch because in the public
speaking since lower pitches like you
more have more confidence so this is
another example where we're trying to
look at this kind of automatic response
to get people to change their behavior
in real time and if we can do it real
time all the time we don't have to have
to worry about technology that or it
will it will someone use it for the long
time because if you can get the same
the fact all the time when you solve
that problem but we don't kind of know
that I know that yet but ultimately I
think we're kind of I think this kind of
vision of making technology disappear is
what we are after both from the sensing
and intervention side and really I think
both are necessary when we're designing
technology in the mental health well I
want to kind of this is my group in
terms of all the people have kind of
contributed in the various aspects of
the work that I presented so with that I
thank everyone for coming for questions
okay yeah so as you were looking at some
of the day earlier your presentation of
how much can you measure those results
sort of absolutely versus how much do
you have dependent having some sort of a
baseline where the person isn't
depressed or isn't a undergoing of an
episode so I think in a lot of those
cases having some baseline information
is crucial either so you may have to
make some assumption so in some cases
what so the the study I didn't talk
about this the depression with chronic
illness we're actually setting some
baseline based on clinician information
where we don't know whether where they
are in their kind of cycle but
ultimately if you can see the ups and
downs you can automatically kind of info
say what's what should be the baseline
but right now we're we are either making
certain assumption or setting it based
on the clinician input yeah that's very
important like others unless we know
there's a line to personal very
organized someone who's finally fast
eater right so you need to know how it's
changing and oftentimes our features
that we look at is our Delta's so we
never look at the absolute value we're
looking at Delta changes kind of the
particularly the longitudinal on one
pretty much all of them are kind of
changes over time yeah
um would you be able to a confident I've
so what I mean is for example someone
who's going to say under like a
high-stress job versus someone else is
not so the distress that would be
thinking them I mean charts on helping
but it may not be something that's from
for rather an external signals even even
in a those used to high stress
environment can the continuous stress
can have a negative mental health effect
right but one of the things and we are
doing some study with student health
population now is what the talk about is
resilient right some people are more
resilient to dealing with stress than
others and can we actually identify what
are some of the behavioral traits of
those who are resilient we haven't done
that yet but that's a very interesting
question because it's not that high
stress people in high-stress environment
can cope better not everyone can it's
much more about their ability to kind of
copán there's a lot of variability there
so the idea is that can you actually
identify those who have lower resilience
and help them earlier on so that's
that's a good question but we haven't
done that yet yeah it's a great talk
thank you um I'm wondering about your
studies with schizophrenia patients and
how you deal with the potential for
paranoia because you know specially when
you talk about technology becoming
invisible and I imagine that triggering
some paranoid thinking yeah that's how I
disorder them yeah so that's that's an
excellent question I I think so when we
were doing that schizophrenia study we
first like submitted a grant proposal to
NSF which got thrown back at our face
because they thought that patient would
never use it and then we sent it to NIH
where we actually had skipped to free
the experts in the review panel and we
got like a like fun dad like an ro1 grin
and which kind of tells you like
understanding the patient population is
important and we actually did a lot of
surveys in terms of we explain this is
what the technology is doing would you
use it would you even
over this study and we actually told
them that if you explained to them and
explain the potential benefit and
they're in a kind of cognitive state to
understand it it was actually not a
barrier and we're not the fair we did
that but actually there is a lot of
history so there's a schizophrenia
researcher at Dartmouth called drove and
ZEB he has done a lot of extensive study
with patients to look at the
receptiveness even if they have paranoia
hallucinations and and partly because
they're also keenly aware that how
changes in their state affects the
quality of life so obviously it matters
who is going to see their data and how
how it's being protected to an extent
but they also see the benefit of it has
a huge impact on their quality of life
so I totally in the end we didn't find
that to be a barrier if it's properly
explained and they transition into a
relapse because I can see people
dropping off yes a lot of the things
that we saw is actually they're
answering self-report question decreased
or sometimes completely was disappeared
but the the sensing we had had more
issues about charging their phones but
actually nobody turned off and we
actually showed explicitly how they can
turn off we had that in one case of all
all the ones where they turned off
everything so we didn't see that but
that's that I think that's still a
question that we need to understand more
and as we get the full data and we
talked to the clinician that we need to
get a better understanding but at least
it's been it hasn't been as negative
let's take it it than we thought it
would be actually to be honest yeah we
should wrap it there and if there's a
couple more questions you have some more
minutes down thank you
you